Diane Guerrero has appeared in the
highly rated TV series TV shows orange
is the new black and Jane the virgin her
new book in the country reel of my
family divided is a compelling and
moving memoir which has received praise
from the literary community
Diane volunteers with the nonprofit
immigrant legal Resource Center and with
me familia vota an organization that
promotes civil involvement she has also
been named an ambassador for citizenship
and Naturalization by the white house
tonight she is joined in by the
Baltimore Sun's award-winning education
reporter Liz Bowie and Liz Lee thank you
very much for being here and moderating
this conversation with I am
please welcome Diane and Liz to the
Pratt library hello good evening can you
all hear us hello
oh this does work well I just wanted to
start the conversation off by having
Diane tell you you you probably know of
her it's an actress but maybe you don't
know her backstory so I wanted to ask
her just to give us the briefest of
introductions about her story just the
sort of structure of it and and who she
is thank you
Thank You Liz thank you Judy and thank
you a Pratt library and thank you to all
of you for being here today I am I feel
so honored that you guys came out to
hear me speak I'll try my best
um well my name is Diane Guerrero
my parents are Colombian immigrants I
was born in New Jersey but I was raised
in Boston Boston anybody now yes my
parents came here with a visa in Hope I
mean this story changes sometimes being
my dad you know they sometimes they say
you know we we were just going to see
how you know
check out this dais or you know you know
my mother had hopes of staying and
making a family here and making her
dreams come true of course and
eventually their visa expired and they
wanted to try to figure out a way to
become citizens
so that was their journey in their quest
so they were undocumented for as long as
I can remember and my childhood was
shaped by that by that fact my parents
were very honest with me
as a young girl I knew what their status
was and I knew very clearly what my
status was I was an American citizen and
they weren't so they I had something
that they wanted very desperately and
they made it very clear that they needed
that so that we could stay together so I
remember every prayer every wish was
that my parents got these papers that
they needed so that we could stay
together we managed to live our lives
and but it was certainly scary and I
know that anybody who has been through
this experience knows how intense it is
and how interesting your life can become
when you're living in the shadows so I I
grew up with this dream but I also had
another dream I had the dream of maybe
one day becoming an entertainer
performer an artist and so when my
parents
my parents were deported because of
their lack of documents I decided to
stay and pursue my dream which was to
stay here and and finish my education
and and and try to live out my own dream
in the country we love I know it's corny
but I always put that in there because
yesterday I was like I was making this
video for this event and you know why I
put that in there I said in the country
we love and then like I winked so like
because I felt embarrassed and my friend
was like you know own that just own it
it is the country you love so own it so
now I'm I'm not winking I'm saying them
so I could stay in the country we love
and pursue my my dreams and form my own
life and and then I so here we are I you
know I think 1415 years passed and I
wasn't dealing with the huge cloud over
my life which was this whole issue of
immigration and I started seeing the
topic come up a lot in the news and and
you know and people you know day to day
conversation so you know the word
immigration would come up and I my ears
would like you know start ringing and I
would want to talk about it but I
couldn't because I felt you know all
sorts of stuff you know I had a lot of
issues with because my parents were
deported and I didn't want to really
want to deal with that but then I saw
that there was a need to use my voice in
this way and so I started little by
little I wrote an op-ed just kind of
feeling the waters out I was just like I
didn't think anybody would read the
op-ed of course I was like I'm going to
do this but no one's going to read it so
it's all good it's sort of how I've
lived my life really is by trying things
out and telling myself that no one's
ever going to see it nothing's ever
going to come of it but I'm just going
to try it right
and I tried and people did read it and
it did get some sort of attention and
then I realized that it was such an
important issue that I had to talk about
and I had to talk about it because I had
been through this experience and I knew
that millions of people were going
through the same thing and our country
needed voices like mine people who had
been through it firsthand and could
share a human story and and kind of be
part of the conversation and then you
know lalala
lots of stuff happen and then I wrote
this book and now I'm here so was that
too long no now that exact rate and I
think one of the really interesting
things about the book is that and I've
worked a lot on stories about
immigration in the last year so I think
one of the really interesting things is
that we hear so much about the journeys
to America from people all over the
world but we don't always hear what
happens once they're here we don't
always hear the voice of the child who
whose parents are deported we don't hear
how is it if you're an Iraqi girl and
you arrive in Baltimore what happens
after you get here and so I think those
voices are really important to be heard
more I wanted to ask Diane to read sort
of a crucial moment in the in the book
her book when I just set this up a
little and she once her parents were
taken out of the house they were
detained for a while in prison so she
could go and visit them so she went to
sort of say goodbye to her mom and I'll
let you start from there especially this
is in the prison yeah okay and excuse me
if I if I love or anything I have some
learning disabilities it's not funny but
it's true
all right here we go I know not the best
profession I was like I want to be
doctor you know just always challenging
myself and okay here it goes
you ready Amelia asked I stood and
pivoted so I could avoid mommy's face as
much as I longed to see her I also
didn't want to remember her like this
not with her wrists chained up not in an
orange jumpsuit the person behind that
barrier wasn't my mother she was a
stranger to me with hardly a sound a
group the group shuffled back down the
corridor
Amelia held my hand wildly walked this
isn't the end for you Diane she said as
she tried to reassure me but it felt
like the end as devastated as I was for
my mom I was even more scared for myself
she and my dad were going home to family
I was stepping into a future I prayed
would never come outside
Amelia peered out over the lot trying to
recall where she parked her Camry a few
hundred feet away from us near the
prison side entrance a white police van
pulled up Amelia and I exchanged a look
seconds later two guards herded some
inmates out into the curb my mother was
among them
just as my mother was stepping into the
paddy wagon she turned around and caught
a glimpse of me she froze I could tell
she wanted to say something to run to me
but before she could make a move a guard
rushed her into the van let's go he
snapped the engine rumbled on from her
seat in the rear mami twisted herself
around so she could see me through the
bars on the windows she was trying to
tell me something but I couldn't figure
out what it was then all at once I
understood I love you she was mouthing I
love you I love you I love you
she repeats she repeated the three words
until the van turned from the lot and
disappeared I smiled that was the only
thing that I could be sure of that my
mother loved me [ __ ] anyone who tried to
come between us this was me my teenage
years the summer I lost my parents it
was the strangest kind of heartache no
friends gathered to grieve over the
departed no flowers were sent no
memorial service was planned and yet the
two people I cherish the most were gone
not from the world itself but gone from
me we'd find a way to move forward to
carry on just not with the promise of
one another's presence thank you sorry
if there are any children in the
audience for me I've learned one of the
things that I think is not well
understood outside of the Latino
immigrant community is the extent of the
divisions that the immigration
experience has on families and in my
work and as the vault in the as a
reporter for the Baltimore Sun I spent
six or eight months at Patterson High
School in East Baltimore and wrote a
series about that does profiling three
students one of them was the Latino boy
named excel but again and again during
that reporting experience I heard
particularly the boys that undocumented
voice had made it across the border they
told stories about their mother's or
Father's disappearing from them usually
their parents didn't tell them that they
were going to leave Honduras or out file
the door
and they last sometimes in the middle of
the night or while they were at school
and couldn't actually bear to say
goodbye to their children so they just
left and in one case one of the boys
said he came home from school and
realized his mother was gone and
everyone was crying and he couldn't
figure it out in another case a boy told
me that he knew his he was told that his
mother was going to just take a bus to
another town but he knew something was
terribly wrong and he ran with all his
might to see her before she got on the
bus and she did just barely glimpsed her
leaving and she was crying and he was
crying and he didn't see her for eight
years that happens so often I think and
when when the kids are reunited you
would think that oh my gosh this is this
is the most wonderful thing in the world
to be reunited with my moms I haven't
seen but in fact it's terribly difficult
because you don't really know them
they're they're really strangers to you
and many and there's this is such a
problem in the Latino immigrant
community that they have now the
teachers have started developing
curriculum that helps parents and their
children who they've been apart from for
a long time reunite because until you
reunite you really can't move on in many
ways in your new country so I think
Diane story is a little bit different
but it's a twist on that same that same
theme of having years and years apart
and not being able to communicate in a
real way and having to sort of separate
and I think Dinah I would ask you to
tell a little bit about that separation
for you and what it did for you and your
insides and then how you came back
around right
well yeah I mean it it's very difficult
to um you know when I went through that
but that separation from your folks
because like I said in my family unit
had died that day and you know for you
there you're it's like a death but no
one treats it as that because they're
alive obviously your parents are alive
but your family unit has died so you
have to sort of move on I mean you
either move on or you go back I chose to
move on and stay here and and continue
my life in the States you know in the
way that in it and I thought I figured
I'd figure it out you know all I knew
that I all I knew was that I needed my
education and this is what my parents
had taught me you need your education
and you need to if you work really hard
then you'll make something out of
yourself and that was what I believed
you know as a kid growing up in the
States this was where I could do that
you know every you know I knew that I
could do this here and I could be
resourceful and if I was savvy enough
and I was determined enough that
something could happen that I could make
something happen but what I guess I
didn't realize that that age was what
the relationship was going to be with my
folks and for some reason I thought okay
we will figure that out too but what I
didn't realize was the huge strain that
it had on us and what it had on our
emotional life and our and our and our
psychological and the psychological
impact that it would have on me so I
wanted to talk about that in the book
that just a strained relationship and
that it the effects that has on a family
to be separated like that you know no
one talks about the psychological and
emotional damage because no one sees
this as really I mean when you hear it
on the news when you hear politicians
talk about it you never hear it as
human issue and it's all political but
it's important to realize that these are
real people and real families and there
are real effects and I was lucky enough
to sort of come back from that but I was
like I was in a very deep hole for a
very long time I didn't speak to my
parents or didn't see them for maybe
eight years because the pain was it was
too much I didn't know how to handle it
I would go back to Colombia and I would
visit them and I didn't know what to do
because I was growing and they were
growing and I figured you know those are
my parents they'll stay the same but you
know they grow too they changed and your
mother absolutely just didn't give up I
mean she kept calling and calling and
calling and calling and you would like a
teenager would you just said no I'm not
going to deal with you yeah I mean there
was a point where I sort of I didn't
know how to handle it so I had to
separate myself and and I feel like
sometimes you know in a way that sort of
gave me legs to continue I mean I did
the best that I could you know I didn't
know how to I love it you like shaky I'm
like I always look at you he's like yeah
yeah I get out in it I didn't I didn't
really know how to how to be an adult
and handle things correctly so I just
did the best that I could and sometimes
shutting down was the only way that I
could move forward and I think the way
that I mean it took me 14 15 I mean just
until a few years ago I mean my my
family relationship I'm still um you
know have to work at it every day I mean
my mother was like pissed at me
yesterday for something you know I mean
for like me not being responsive enough
or me not showing her the kind of you
know emotion that she wants she wanted
for me
so it's work every day and sometimes we
I mean I think that that's the only
thing I mean yeah being apart but it's
just it's the relationship that was so
strained and that I wish I could get
back but you know you have to do the
best you can we were talking about
technology and how
sort of that's been a part of has played
a huge part in us kind of reconnecting
and obviously my work with immigration
reform has kind of helped my mind and my
heart sort of heal so that I could you
know accept my life and accept our
relationship the way it is and just love
it for what it is and and continue that
way and just like you know you gotta
just adjust to whatever life has given
you and try to make the best out of that
and that's what I've tried to do you
know with this work and so I sort of
have done this I mean obviously so I
could help others and share with others
but also so I could help me and my
family because we needed something I
needed like in my in my fashion I always
you know I go big or I go home so I had
to like do this so that I could try to
salvage through the relationships my
parents I needed to open my heart to
this work so that I could I mean
actually you also needed to repair those
relationships that seems well until you
could go on with your life in a really
productive way yeah yeah yeah I mean it
was a big deal when you went to see your
mom and repaired that relationship after
so long yeah and it's yeah and like I
said it's repairing everyday yes I said
she was a really nasty yesterday oh man
hurry so I wondered I wanted you to talk
a little bit about becoming an actress
and if you thought that the sort of grit
and perseverance that you needed to get
through the years without your parents
had then helped you become an actress
you know that you were willing to sort
of stick it out through a lot of
auditions that didn't work out or long
times between between work and yeah yeah
this kind of work is very up and down I
mean I still like every day I get a call
you know like trying to figure out my
life and what my next move is because
you know
it's gig by gig you know it's not it's
not a sure thing this business is not a
sure thing and I mean I knew that I mean
the reason why I didn't want to take the
chance in the beginning what I was
scared of was because I didn't have you
know that foundation or that base that I
know that you need to pursue anything
you know I mean you need that support
from your family members but yeah I
think you're right I feel like at the
time that I decided to pursue what I
really wanted to do I really had to say
I just had to say it you know I mean
like I mean I've already been through so
much I mean what people are going to say
no to me you know whatever like I say no
to me you know I've already been through
so much already lost my parents
everybody lost the one thing that that
meant the world to me so I felt like it
totally just prepared me for the amount
of rejection specialized that I got and
you just you know I grew up I grew up
but yeah I think that that everything
that I went through in high school and
and after that like everything like
going to college was a huge miracle for
me I don't even know how it happened I
still don't know but doing that and then
like doing the things that I got to do
and having the support in my community
that I got it I don't know how it
happened but I know that I was in need
and I needed to be resourceful
I needed to be respectful I needed to
when I say respectful meeting keep my
place you know be grateful to others who
were helping me along this journey and I
think that's all served me you know it's
all served me and I and I don't think
you need to go through something like
this to carry that with you being
resourceful being respectful being
what's the other are even other are
usually I'll remember what boom girl you
got it resilient yes that's the big one
resilient like what's the other one that
I do all the time
yes resilient I knew that I had to do
those though it really it really has
served me well yeah yes
I'm so enduring in so from the time that
your parents left to fairly recently
actually the fact that your parents were
you know undocumented and had been
deported you kept a complete secret even
from people you were pretty close to in
your life and so I wondered what the
transition was like you know sort of
suddenly burying all of this well I
think that I mean for a long time I feel
like my immediate friends knew like the
kids who I grew up with knew some of
them knew it would happen to me and I
don't know sometimes I felt like it held
me back like I I knew first of all I'm a
very happy person I'm a very you know
outgoing person so I felt like if I ever
told this story people would look at me
differently I was ashamed also I mean in
this culture you're you're taught sort
of or from the images that you see on TV
or the sort of rhetoric that you hear
from people is just like if you're an
immigrant you're a bad person if you're
deported then you are a failure so I was
ashamed and I didn't want to share that
and I didn't want people to look at me
differently
and then you know once things started
escalating like the topic started coming
up more and more and I feel like it's
come up even like now obviously more
than ever which is why I was compelled
to talk about it but it was like an
explosion when you know I was here
like I was like I said I would hear
somebody talk about it and I would want
to say something to it or I would say
something really bold and people be like
where'd that come from and I'm like what
no nothing I'm just I didn't know you're
passionate about like that immigration
you know nation of immigrants that's all
obvious ah no biggie
um and so when I when I basically shared
that with people and in the way that I
did I I felt that the response was very
it was cool it was it was it was really
open and and people were accepting and I
learned that day that if you just you
know there's no shame in your story
there's no shame where you come from who
you are and and you need to use that you
know it so if you're if you find
yourself in a place where you're unhappy
and you want to you're unhappy with the
current system or something is not right
you wake up and you're like I'm not into
that I'm not into the raids that are
happening right now I there should be
you know a path for citizenship I don't
really understand the immigration system
it doesn't seem it seems a little foggy
I feel like the majority of people in
this country don't really understand it
and then you decide to be a part of a
solution or trying to find a solution
and then that and so I felt it was just
worth it to share my story at that point
there there are a lot of things going on
in immigration right now and one of the
things that I discussed earlier was I
felt that that social media has really
changed immigration in this country if
you think back a hundred years ago
people came over to the United States
and you know they got off the boat and
that was it they they didn't talk to
their family except through letters and
those letters took a long time getting
here and back and today the new
immigrants that I speak with like the
refugees who have left Iraq or or
they've left any country really are
still so connected through Facebook and
Twitter and texting and you know it's
really free to be in touch with your
friends so they never in a way it's a
wonderful comfort for them to be able to
talk to their relatives I talked to a
searing
family who the mother is left behind in
Turkey with one of the children and the
rest of the family is here and they
Skype at dinner every night so they have
dinner together over Skype but they
can't unite which is a wonderful thing
in one sense in another way it can be
horribly debilitating because you can
never sort of really leave your country
behind so for instance I would I profile
the Iraqi girl who left her fiance back
in Baghdad and for the first year and a
half she was here she was constantly
Facebook messaging him dozens of times
every day she's finally broken off with
him but that that sense that you know I
can't I can't really go on with my life
here so it's a wonderful thing to have
to be able to be in touch with your
parents so quickly but it's also can be
a detriment and you were talking about
how you always feel that there's a that
people kill you should drop everything
when they call yeah yeah I mean you
certainly I mean the way our culture
some of our culture's are that the
family is everything right
our parents are everything and and you
have sort of this responsibility
especially if you have this opportunity
this great opportunity to be here in the
United States to you know sort of
provide or to be attentive and to be
there I mean bully I look I wish that
bug bit me because I don't want to talk
to anybody
I wish man that that wasn't funny but
you know if I I find if I you know Skype
with my mom during dinner every night
she's like love it
unfortunately I'm Way too American for
that I'm like I'm going to watch TV
but now I mean there has to be a balance
right I mean I still feel that
responsibility which is like it means
you know I wake up screaming sometimes
oh my god you know I find so much on my
mind and I want to do so much I want to
do so much for my family but there's
just you know there has to be a moment
where you balance and you say okay I
have to live for me I have to do what I
have to do and take care of myself in
order to help others and and I did that
sort of along my journey in different
ways I didn't have a balance so I just
like to shut people out but I'm going to
go out for my dreams today you know and
I'm not going to let anyone stop me
including my family but of course that
make me happy it made me incredibly
depressed so you just have to find a
balance and another thing I would say
about technology though is that how it's
easy it is to obviously share
information and information like you
know what's going on in the world or you
know what kind of movement we want or
we're kind of you know what what is
troubling our society and things like
that and we can share information so
much faster and that's a good thing I
think especially for the Latino
community who I think now is getting
most of their information are their news
online there is a lot more people that
can have an opinion a lot more people
that can write articles who are who are
just using their voices so in that in
that sense I think it's really good
would you just talk it will come full
circle now and just maybe talk a little
bit about where you see immigration
reform going and what your hope is for
the future obviously there's some vast
difference of opinion among the
presidential candidates so maybe you
could just talk about how how you think
we could get through this sure um well I
think
I think obviously having this
conversation right now is a step forward
I think that we need to have well first
first and foremost I think in my opinion
we need immigration reform along with a
lot of the groups and organizations that
I'm working with we need immigration
reform we think that the immigration
system in this country is outdated as
you see a lot of people are affected
every year every day and nothing is
being done and we've had the system for
a very long time the visa system is
outdated and of course the way we handle
family separation is not a good thing
I feel like there are there are a lot
more people getting involved and and
actually talking about this issue I
think that still like I still I still
think a lot of people don't know what
we're dealing with I don't know where
the future of immigration reform is
going I don't see it happening
I wish it could happen sometime soon I
wish deportations would stop I wish that
we could have a friendlier conversation
about immigrants and what they mean to
this country I hope that we can change
the culture in which we talk about
immigration and undocumented people and
see all the contributions that those
immigrant communities make I feel there
needs to be a clear and fair path to
citizenship and I feel like the people
that are here already deserve to
contribute to this country legally I
don't think any I don't think any
immigrant or undocumented family that I
that I have ever talked to is here
saying I don't want any documents I
don't want to become a citizen I don't
you know I feel like everyone who I talk
to and and I know it from firsthand
because I know how much my parents love
this country
I know how hard they fought to find a
path to become citizens to become
documented so they're just there there
needs to be more talk about reform and
less talk about division and and kickin
out and building walls and and all the
things and again I'm not like advocating
for people to come over and I think that
it's silly to think that everyone in the
world wants to be here because that's
not true I just think that there needs
to be some sort of just a plan for the
people who are already here and who have
made lives here yeah I think we can have
some question so if we one is people in
it oh there's a microphone and I ask
that you go to that just go up it just
run up there
[Music]
you
we heard by everyone so my question is
kind of about your experience because
you are very kind of brown baking TV
shows right now Jane the Virgin
obviously had a lot to say and has done
a lot for women's television in some
ways and are in Germany orange is the
new black and said a lot to tell women
choice so but that those are kind of
great pop for him and I know on Jane the
Virgin there was a whole storyline about
Alba being an undocumented [ __ ] again I
was wondering if you would have any
input on that and if you have any input
on the show that moment who might be
facing similar situations and pigeons
for orange is the new black yeah well I
will thank you so much and well first
I'm so proud to be on both on two shows
that are so social and who comment on we
know what's happening socially right I
think that's why we've come to love both
shows so much because they sort of like
share what's really happening in the
world and sharing stories that we have
haven't really heard part of what I said
like when I said about changing the
culture right I feel like television
shows and entertainment have a
responsibility to to bring force those
issues so that we can talk about them I
think that's why I was such a huge deal
I mean when when Jane the Virgin had
that storyline and then you know typed
in hashtag immigration reform and it was
just it was like this tiny little thing
and it was a quick mention and it
reached so many people right I think
that you see the power of what you know
shows like this have
and the huge responsibility that is in
the entertainment system
not this time sorry industry in the
entertainment industry have you know to
use our platform to raise these issues
so we can talk about them so that you
know we can get involved and so that we
can know the power of our voices and our
the power of our actions and and
participation I hope that more shows can
take a look at shows like oranges in
black and Jain and sort of and take from
from that I think that we're doing it
slowly but I'm certainly being part of
those shows definitely motivated me to
be more active and saying you know it
made me feel like I had a voice too and
and how I should use it you know being
around so many women who care about how
many things and actually doing something
about it
even the smallest way by just typing
something that you care about her going
into it you know working with an
organization and and lending you know
your time or or trying to motivate
others to fight for some things to fight
for something that they believe in I
think is really cool thank you thank you
hello hello they my name is Alfredo and
a little bit starstruck right now
because uh I mean well I just was
watching the third season of orange is
the new black for that week yes yeah and
we're looking forward to the fourth
season so it's like for my co-workers by
the way so I'm glad to be here in front
of you and I just purchased your book
too so I can't wait to read it
um so I want to go back a little to your
store your personal story parents will
report it I mean family is everything
and to come home and not see your
parents do I can imagine that with
learning systems in place to support you
or evertune [ __ ] or at you aware of any
support other unity that you may choose
not to access that type of support yeah
no I hear there were none I mean when
the whole thing happened and I talked
about this all the time I we waited I
waited
to see if someone would come or I would
get a call or even in school and no one
ever came and it was sort of I mean I
sure as hell didn't you know I didn't
want to go and I didn't I was afraid
that I did sliding goes to the police I
didn't like I didn't contact anybody to
say hey I'm like here by myself I sort
of just we sort of made the decision
that I would stay with friends but I
didn't know of any programs I didn't
know of any organizations that can help
me and I think that part of me getting
involved like this and writing this book
and sitting here with you is because I'm
trying to reach those who are going
through the same thing or who knows
someone who's going through the same
thing a child left behind to sort of
motivate them to to tell them and say
there are organizations out there and
there are websites out there and there
is literature out there that you can
read and you can educate yourself I
think that that you know I talk about
how that is sort of one of the things
that I I'm sad that you know that we
were so scared and we were living in
such fear that we didn't go out there
and educate ourselves really and what
our options were and what our rights
were and what we could do and who we can
seek for help so I think right now I'm
doing my best to express that and to say
that there are places out there that you
can go to there are organizations out
there that are willing to help that are
willing to educate you and you should
definitely definitely take advantage of
it so that you don't you're not staying
at home and fear you're trying to help
your situation and help your family out
right like programs with daca and DAPA
and good well what I was going to say
was it one of the really horrifying
moments in the book is actually the fact
that ice came in and took her parents
and never fought or never then followed
up and said well there's a child living
in this house so what's going to happen
to that child so they just took the
parents and left so if you think about a
family that's not as resourceful
you and your I mean your parents took
care made sure that there was somebody
there even from prison made sure there
was somebody there for that her but but
the idea that that the federal
government would basically take an
eight-year-olds parents away and then
not follow through to make sure that
eight-year-old has foster care or those
great those great the system failed to
failed her but I want this congratulate
you on being resilient you reflects me
not a Latino immigrant the Liam
Baltimore did I work with and that I'm
proud to call my family and friends so
definitely people ok the filter people
and we check that they're not pressing
nothing I good evening my name is
Julianna I work for a comprehensive
immigrant Resource Center here in
Baltimore called the Esperanza Center
and I just wanted to thank you because
we rely a lot on GI LRC's resources the
red card all of the know your rights
cards were of life-giving in December
during the deportation priorities and as
a person that works with immigrants and
particularly immigration law I was
curious and maybe like a little cheese
massa
have you tried going through the process
of petitioning for your parents to come
back or are your parents interested in
coming back and if you're in the process
of doing that how much of a headache
has it been and can you speak a little
bit about a little bit more because I
know in your book and you've mentioned a
little bit about what a headache about
process is for all the people that say
you know get in line do it correctly
right how long is he because I don't
think a lot of people are not aware of
how much it is so I'm like yeah well
first first I have to say but it's
definitely cheese most out of you but I
love it
I feel like we're all a little bit of
family you know I get yeah we're so
close I know I have to say that yes they
want to come back and I want them back
and right now I'm going through that
process and it is very very difficult I
mean the amount of paperwork that goes
in it and you know they have to you know
they have to remember all these dates
and all this thing and you know it's
difficult and yes we want to I want them
to like I just want them to be able to
visit you know I mean I think that's my
goal I'm not even I don't even
expectations are pretty low but but even
that is really difficult it is really
hard but I am trying I don't think I'll
ever stop trying because I love them and
I want them to see me grow and I want
them to see my family when when I you
know when that happens clock is ticking
people but it's happening I mean you
know it I every day I miss my mother you
know I want to I want to go to home
goods with her I want to just go to the
grocery store you know things like that
and I can go and do that when I go to
Colombia but it's not the same you know
to know that she is in my home she is
you know in this country in my country
which I also consider her part of Jill
so it is very difficult to process and
but thank God for the immigration legal
Resource Center who I volunteer with
they have been so helpful and
organizations like that just provide
like your organization provides all the
information that I need so that I don't
do any mistakes and any mistake miss
gaps because anyone will tell you that
has been through this process any single
like mistake can just you'll have to
just start from the beginning and
whatever that beginning is and you know
there are so many roadblocks for it like
I said there is no clear path and there
is no back of the line so thank you
thank you so much I think your again for
coming here today
I am a teacher here in the city I teach
at Baltimore City College which is a
high school city forever I see some city
alone and city teachers and I'm also an
advisor for our student organization
which is still most students organizing
I'm multi multi cultural open society to
us she's one of the person so what I
wanted to hear about was how could the
school system has better supported you
what do you think school should be doing
this is happening it's happening in our
communities we know our our students are
being affected
what is the role that you see in schools
in this and how can we be there for our
students better well first of all I mean
when I was growing up I had no sort of
education when it came to immigration
and our immigration system and just
there just learning about it I think our
having it be part of the curriculum
would be very helpful I think that it
put new programs need to be in place
like the program that that you were
talking about earlier which is what did
they do they I don't know oh the
reunification reunification yeah
curriculum yeah curriculum I think are
so helpful I think having an open
conversation about it and and teaching
your students and also like I said with
when changing the language and the
culture it's like you know knowing that
we don't that no person no one person is
illegal right that we need to change
that type of language and and also know
that immigrants and even people here who
are undocumented undocumented make up
part of what America is and and what
this country is so in stories like mine
that many people share sharing those and
being open about stories like this and
knowing that that is a part of our
American story that just because my
parents were undocumented just because I
was I'm the daughter of undocumented
people doesn't make me less American
than anyone else
so I think that way will will start
having better conversations about it and
maybe more solutions and maybe you know
involving people so that they could be
more civically engaged you know the
importance of voting the importance of
participating and being active in your
community so that there were electing
officials who are going to meet our
needs and I don't say that just our
needs as a Latino community or as an
undocumented immigrant community from
everywhere right so from Syria from Iraq
from I say all of us but also American
citizens because it's important for the
entire country for this for this issue
to be addressed for immigration reform
it's important for the entire country I
think it's really interesting that I
what I've seen as an education reporter
that more and more for instance at
Patterson high school that last four
valedictorians have been immigrants and
if you look at at the top of the class
in many high schools across the state
they're immigrants thank you thank you
so teach those kiddies thank you
hi my name is Jasmine I am saying
growing so much right now
I love it well my question is as a young
latina activist I want to know why
advice would you give to young Latino
activists like myself well I mean one
advice is one thing that I have to
remind myself every day is that never to
give up I know it sounds cheesy but you
have to know that your work matters and
your your effort matters and I think
that in order to be part of the solution
we can't stop and we need to continue
the work even though we get just so
disappointed so much I mean you see a
dhaba and daca plus being held up in the
courts right now and that's very
frustrating for all of us but we what we
can do is continue motivating continue
sharing information continue to be
empathetic
and I know that that if we give up
that's the same as like 100 people
giving up right I mean think about think
about that think about obstructionist
right and people who in the past have
obstructed any sort of bill being passed
any sort of bill for immigration reform
or any other bill that you've seen where
where people have fought so hard to to
help have and only a few people have
made enough noise to say no we don't
want this and those few people are
speaking for the entire country and that
happens from lack of participation and
lack of motivation and an endurance I
say we have to keep at it and and never
stop because if imagine if we all use
our voices and if we all continue to be
part of this movement or any movement
imagine all all that we can get done and
all that we can do thank you thank you
good evening my name is Nancy big al
first of all you're really beautiful and
handsome look super gay guys in every
day game I actually have three questions
the first question is since we're in the
election year I would like to know if
you're supporting any candidate second
question is from kidding oh my god I
didn't even save it in ghent second
question is are you passionate I know
you're very passionate buying the
direction obviously but are you
passionate about any other social issues
or women's issues I you know I'd like to
know and third question would be what
are your favorite shows like
I'm a game was an old fans I would like
to know if you watch it okay I'm getting
to that I'm getting to Game of Thrones
it's all my cue for all it when I do I
started like years ago and then I had to
go do something and then I just got
distracted I was like what get a TD
subtly so the first question is I'm
right now the work that I'm doing is
just to make sure that people are voting
and that people are participating I'm
not I don't think I want to not like not
like anybody cares what I say but I'm
not I'm not yet sure and I'm not going
to I'm well I am sure but I'm not going
to say who I'm voting for
I'm just gonna I'm going to keep that
private until like I can just blast and
just doing oh sorry this person but
right now I think that my role and that
I picked up in the beginning was just
that I'm going to focus on participation
and getting people civically engaged and
that's that's the most important it's
like vote whatever you're going to vote
vote for anyone but Trump but wait but
bow for someone and getting get involved
and then second question are you
passionate about any other oh my gosh
I'm passionate about everything girl I'm
talking about so many things I am a
feminist like through and through I'm a
humanist I love animals I like yo the
other day I was like bugging out about
the shark
unlike overfishing I think right now I'm
passionate about you know the
criminalization of our people and and
trying to put a stop to that I'm you
know I I hate guns I think there's so
many things that I'm I want to get
involved in and and all these causes
that that I that I care about and in the
future I hope to participate more I
think right now I'm starting with
immigration but I like to live in a way
where I think everything is you know
thinking about intersectionality right
and knowing that you know one you know
one thing isn't separate from another so
the you know my LGBT brothers and
sisters what their woes are my woes
and I hope that my woes are theirs I
like to think of it like that and on
your third question is well okay right
now I am watching well right I agree I
just finished vinyl but I mean I'm
watching all sorts of stuff a house of
cards of course oranges in black no
biggie and I think I'm going to get into
Sopranos max and then Game of Thrones I
haven't seen your promise I know it's
late but because of Netflix you guys
better Netflix you better you better
show up now you can watch all sorts of
stuff that you you know you missed and I
love binging I love watching things all
I want look really great thank you thank
you so much hi how are you hi I'm loving
time I just want to start by saying that
you're top bun is giving me a lot of
life right now I think it what I'm
actually about to go to the hair salon
and request that it's going to be a lot
of hair but I'm ready and able to
purchase it get it get your life get
your life is this is this is all my life
right now
so I appreciate everything that you're
doing and telling your story and I loved
it so interesting and it's really cool
to see here after Watts new you own
orange is the new black and also in the
version I have a very very serious
question for you right now fan I was
scrolling through you're interested
granby today and I noticed that you
posted a picture of Sailor Mars
yeah so what I want to know is who is
your favorite Sailor Scout earlier when
I asked my boyfriend right here who his
favorite Sailor Scout was he said Sailor
Earth and I had the quickly flap in LA
there is no snare where there's no exact
words there's no Sailor
but if you could be any sailor scalp or
who's your favorite sailor scalp in
general okay well so now I guess the
cats out of the bag
I'm binging Sailor Moon right now
I am busy see my room and I was like I'm
wondering I'm like why I loved I love
this show when I was a kid and sometimes
I get annoyed when she like turns into
like Sailor Moon because it takes like
30 seconds
it's definitely work with them it's
worth it though it's worth it I'm going
through every episode of first of all
like the relationship that like that
Sailor Moon has with with Tuxedo Mask
it's just my Freud piece of gold
relationship was hashtag so I think I
would be I mean and the thing is I
posted Mars but then I was like watching
and also she's so angry I think I'd have
to be like a mix I think that might
might like my like I think I'm think I'm
Sailor Moon I gotta say I mean just
looking at just looking at her
personality traits I think I'm Sailor
Moon I'm actually Sailor Moon so that's
not going to work out you can be Sailor
Mercury like in the background
no I'm now and now I'm C no no Sailor
Moon
we can both be Sailor Moon you can't but
thank you fine Sailor Mars
hello sir hi I don't really have any
questions just like to make two
statements once a week I tutor as a part
of a in Taronga County Public Schools
Hispanic students young seven or eight
years old who are a little bit behind in
her reading yeah
and right now I'm working with Zeus and
he's coming along well but the thing to
impressing those is the strength of
family unit there's not much whole lot
there in their report no doubt very
little English is spoken at home yet
once a week I get a book out of library
and give it to him to work at home and
he comes back and he's worked with with
his mother
she doesn't speak a word of English and
he's done much better now I don't know
how that happens but just the caring of
the father and the mother and the
strength of a family or in his early
impressive and he's going to be okay I
really think that and the second thing
you wouldn't say anything but I will
kind of Republican I'm embarrassed
every day but my party's nominee I'm
mortified by it okay
if you wanted to say okay I hear you and
I and honestly and I I'm willing I think
that it's important to acknowledge that
you know not all Republicans agree with
Donald Trump and his policies and what
he wants to do and I know that and I
mean if you look at years you know a lot
you know a long long time ago you know
there were definitely some like you know
cool Republicans you know Abraham
Lincoln was like a Republican fans I
mean he was cool but I understand you
and I actually that and that's important
and thank you so much for for being here
and listening to me I know I'm sure we
disagree in something but I'm sure we
can have a conversation not much see see
I think in like in general I think
Americans want immigration reform and
they want to see a functioning
immigration system I think that's the
most important thing a functioning
immigration system which right now we
don't have thank you sir hi okay I have
a question but I guess I'll just start
with the statement I wanted to say thank
you for bringing up the fact in your
book that when you are undocumented
you're still paying taxes and like a lot
of talk isn't necessarily put out there
about the fact that like you're
undocumented but your work game but
you're still paying into the Social
Security system and you're never going
to get anything back and it's the
immigrants that you know are putting
that money in there were to be gone all
deported that system what essentially
like how billions out of it that
wouldn't necessarily be there and I
think that's really important knowing
that my parents are in that similar
situation don't say your name don't say
your last name just kidding but um so I
guess like I wanted to say thank you
regarding that because I feel like you
know even with our stories are so
similar with eventually my parents
having to leave as well but so I know
how hard it is for you to get up there
and I know how hard it is for you to and
thank you for being here UK
but um my question is if you help any
insight as to like why like dr. PES but
Obama still like the main person that
has supported so many people out of all
the presidents like it's kind of like an
oxymoron and I just like don't get it
like I hear you hear you and and why you
would be upset about that okay can i
that's weird right I'm gonna sit down -
that's weird I never do that you want I
don't contact like that all right
look I feel you girl and sometimes I get
I wonder why and I get asked that
question a lot and I think that the only
way to think about it is that our
president and any president even though
they do have power they you know it's
it's it's all a team right right
Congress has to be on the same side the
house has to be on the same side the
Senate has to be on the same side and I
think that well first of all I don't
agree with it it sucks a downright sucks
that he has deported a lot of our
families and and but it's not just him
right I think that he did try to pass a
bill years ago that you know wasn't that
was stopped by the house and and that
was and that was you know that was
really bad for all of us and and for
ultimately the the administration having
to make those really tough decisions I
think that we have to just keep on we
have to hold we have absolutely have to
hold are the people who we elect an
office accountable and we just have to
keep an eye on on people that's why
participation is so important that's why
you being here is so important that's
why you're emotion right now
what you're feeling is so important
because we can turn that into action I
don't have all the answers and I'm sure
President Obama doesn't have all the
answers either and I'm sure you know
it's just it's a really difficult thing
and that's why it's so so important that
immigration reform is on the forefront
whoever we elect we express how
important that is for all of us and not
just people who are going well
definitely us who are going through in
this who are going through this
situation so kids of undocumented folks
and and I'm kids of undocumented
communities but also American citizens
and people who are maybe not necessarily
so close to the issue so I'm sorry I
know what you're feeling girl I get it I
get it but that's why you have to get be
involved more than ever all right hi hi
um so thank you so my parents are
immigrants but your parents what are
immigrants yes but they repatriated
voluntarily if you use ago and I was in
college and that took a lot of years of
grieving without me knowing it but I
just want to ask you about some a
milestone in your journey and just
reconciling your relationship I think
conceptually with your parents you know
the responsibilities they're in and your
being by cultural the privilege that you
have that they didn't have and how
you're a creative work influenced maybe
the ways that you've reconciled who you
are in light of your parents on the
situation identity ah laughter mm-hmm
yeah well you know it's a battle every
day sometimes I'm like I look at myself
and I'm you know I the the title of my
book is my family divided but in a lot
of ways it's me divided right my life
divided and it's been a lot of you know
struggles figuring out who I am and who
I want to be and you know am i bad am i
a latina woman I am I'm an American
you know where do I belong but I think I
just by accepting my story accepting
sort of what happened to us and
accepting not in the way it's like oh
yeah I'm totally cool with it
no accepting meaning
you know knowing that it happened except
you know taking it in and now and taking
some action and doing and some of the
work that I'm doing now I think I just
have to remember that I am always going
to have my culture and what my parents
what I learned from my parents and I'm
always going to be have you know the
Colombian culture that my parents
instilled in me and then the American
culture that I got by living here and
I'm an American all the time in a
mattina all the time so there's no
separation I think that we need to
continue to tell ourselves that that
there's no separation I'm your Asian
American or whatever it is you know you
just boom right
you're that all the time and that is
part of this culture that's part of
America what America is and you're no
less than anyone else and that's the way
you're going to be by accepting yourself
you are going to be able to help others
and help build this country to its you
know fullest potential or to make it the
best that it can be I guess I would say
that if I can I love good you know it's
free cheesy but Amy Tan they spoke to me
as immigrants daughter Chinese
immigrants have you do you have you
found any other work that really kind of
spoke to the really informs the way that
you your your role as a daughter spoke
to kind of your experience that you
connected with a lot that are maybe more
recent than good luck or whatever Amy
Tan an experience that I felt that no
just like works books movies that that
really kind of you related to oh that
spoke to me I mean I I love the work
that rosario Dawson is doing right now I
mean I really look up to her she's she's
a fellow you know she's she's part of
this movement
with me and she works with voter Latino
and her work over the years with civic
engagement and
and and participation has been wonderful
and now she's just been so outspoken and
very bold and I think that I've seen a
lot of her work and and I've been
inspired and there's something I mean
and there's so many I mean I honestly
get I get articles from students who are
you know studying to be immigration
lawyers or just lawyers or just people
who are just working to to to make it
different and I'm so inspired by by them
so I would say that thank you so much
obviously we've heard a lot of stories
tonight and some people in the audience
why should you think mainstream
television is buddy-boy like what should
the next big story be that covers some
of these topics that we talked about
tonight
well I think every I think I think in
the next I mean the next shows that are
being produced should absolutely always
I mean I mean should always cover social
issues and some of some of the things
that we're going through and I mean this
what we're doing right the work that
we're doing should be reflecting our
current society and always the next show
should be maybe my story you know who
knows I mean I want I want to create
something so that I could inform the
public about what's going on say what I
want to say and and involve that you
know everything that I care about and
everything that we create should always
have that in essence at its core is I
want to say something I want to change
something so I think every show should
strive to that whether it's comedy or
drama or whatever it is it should always
comment on on what's happening that's
what art is right that's what the best
art is right with rock pop yes thank you
thank you thank you so much Diane and
Liz for a very stimulating informative
conversation thank you also to the
audience for your participation the Ivy
bookshop is here this evening and there
Diann will be finding copies of her book
at the desk back here thank you again
[Applause]